we are so pumped about Toy Story 4 and
can't wait to know what happens these
fan series are blowing our minds
stay tuned for some wild theories that
actually make total sense oh yeah
flash-forward at the end of Toy Story 3
and he went off to college and gave all
his toys to Bonnie
he'll be there for you no matter what
but in the trailer for the new Toy Story
movie we see a familiar boy in a red
cowboy hat he's twirling around holding
Jesse and Buzz Lightyear you might think
at first glance that this is Andy
after all he sort of looks like a young
Andy and we know that he used to wear a
red cowboy hat but look closer
that's not Andy they look very similar
but they're definitely not the same kid
and that's not Andy's room either Andy's
room had clouds this room has yellow
stars a lot of fans think that we're
seeing a time jump way into the future
they believe we're seeing Andy's son but
how did Buzz and Jesse find their way to
Andy's kid this theory is pretty
compelling but we still have a lot of
questions woody and bo-peep after the
ending of Toy Story 3 we're pretty sure
that Toy Story 4 will make us cry all
over again but how will it end a lot of
people believe that woody will choose to
stay with bo-peep woody was Andy's toy
and although he loves Bonnie it's just
not the same what would he is on his
adventure he finds Bo Peep Bo was his
one true love but she went missing
sometime between the third and fourth
movie she now lives at a fair and she is
loving the Lost toyless reddit user o
denim thanks woody will stay with Bo
because he finds a new purpose woody is
a great guy and there are lots of lost
toys maybe he stays to help these toys
find a new kid that makes total sense it
seems like something woody would do but
we have another idea what he always had
a knack for finding his way back to Andy
so what if he stays to help the lost
toys find their way back to their
original kids we totally love this
theory Forever Young the toys in Toy
Story are alive but in reality they're
also just toys it all sussed wondering
do they have a normal lifespan if that's
the case woody would be well into his
70s
he's vintage but this fan theory
suggests that the toys are immortal
unless they're totally destroyed these
guys live forever it seems like a great
theory at first but it's actually pretty
sad when you think about it
toys have to go from person to person
over and over again they fall in love
with their kid but then their kid grows
up just like Andy welcome to the club
toys when Bonnie grows up the toys will
basically experience Toy Story 3 all
over again they'll do that till the end
of time that is a lot of goodbyes
goodbye forever according to the trailer
buzz in the gang go after woody and
forkie but they're on a road trip and
they end up at a fair where there are
lots of people and lots of toys it's
going to be hard to find their way back
to Bonnie lots of people think that
woody will stay behind but what about
the rest of the toys Reddit user it's
debatable introduced another ending
theory for Toy Story 4 they think that
it's not just woody who is saying
goodbye all the toys are going to find
new kids he'll end up separated and
never see each other again this theory
makes sense the Toy Story movies have
been growing up the third one was about
childhood ending but there's another
part of growing up they haven't really
covered and that's becoming a busy adult
and senior friends less often than
before if you think saying goodbye to
longtime friends is hard wait until you
hear our last theory the Lotso
connection
remember Lotso he seemed like such a
lovable teddy bear but he was actually
super bitter he was separated from his
human but by the time he made it home he
had been replaced it totally turned his
soul dark woody and Lotso have a lot in
common they were both their kids number
one toy and they both get super jealous
of other toys and he gave woody away to
Bonnie he had to feel pretty rejected
and we can tell he's taken over as
ringleader from the trailer he tells the
toys that they have to be nice to port
eat he's pretty bossy is woody becoming
a mean toy just like lot so we're not
exactly convinced
just hope Lonnie's love is enough to
keep him from turning into a totally
evil cowboy what does it mean to be a
toy the introduction of four key poses
some interesting questions about the Toy
Story universe what does it really mean
to be a toy porky is having a serious
identity crisis he was never supposed to
be able to think and talk he was
supposed to be used once and end up in
the trash but Bonnie puts a face on him
and pleased with him and he comes to
light but toys don't have to have a face
to be alive in Toy Story remember the
edges - this must mean that anything a
child plays with is a toy that can come
to life that may sound cool but it's
actually terrifying there could be lots
of creepy toys out there in Toy Story
for Woody's imagination kids use their
imagination to play with toys and in Toy
Story 3 the toys have their own
imagination and play a Wild West scene
but what if the toys imaginations are a
lot darker than that would he really
liked Bonnie when he met her and he was
really sad that Andy didn't play with
him anymore but what if Andy never gave
his toys to Bonnie
woody might be sitting in a box
somewhere depressed and lonely this
whole world with Bonnie might just be a
figment of Woody's imagination it would
give him something to think about while
he sits and collects us or maybe he has
all the other toys acting this out with
him we can't imagine how hurt they must
have felt when he and he grew up so this
theory makes total sense before you go
let us know if you have any other toy
story for theories of your own in the
comments section and be sure to tell us
if you think woody will return to Bonnie
or stay with his one true beau thanks
for watching hit that big red subscribe
button for more awesome content from the
things and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up we'll catch you
next time
[Music]